so it's nine o'clock on the west coast
so good morning everyone and good
afternoon to those who are joining us
from the East Coast
I'm Alex Vega I'm the co-director of the
East okay centers Coordination Center
so we're wrapping up section two of our
data science seminar which from idea has
been an overview of data representation
issues we've covered a spectrum of
different topics starting with databases
and data warehousing challenges through
to issues related to data wrangling and
exploration and today we're going to
hear about natural language processing
or NLP from dr. know me
ala dad of Columbia University and for
any of you who have had to deal with
either unstructured clinical reports are
the types of data such as biomedical
literature even already appreciate many
the issues of trying to get a computer
to understand a textural document
LT has been and continues to be an
active area of research particularly in
regards to the biomedical space so it's
my pleasure to introduce dr. Ella dad
she is an associate professor of
biomedical informatics at Columbia and
as a data scientist her efforts focus on
the development of techniques for
clinicians patients and health
researchers in the information workflows
extracting and making accessible
information from large clinical data
sets to particular areas of interest in
her research include constitutional
approaches that are firm olive health
phenomena and then account for the
specific biases seen in large chunk
datasets and a translation of these
models into actionable knowledge and
applications dr. Ella dad we're
delighted to have you with us this
morning and so without further ado let's
get started
floor is yours great thank you Alex hi
everyone so I'm gonna be talking to you
that natural language processing and an
open house in particular and the way I
think I'm gonna structures this lecture
is into four topics and I'm gonna spend
most of my time I'm actually this first
two topics first one is to kind of give
you an overview of the applications of
natural language processing in health
and healthcare it's very active field of
research for core NLP methods but you
know for the sake of our of this
audience here I think it's
interesting to think about all the
different ways in which texts and
semi-structured text can be leveraged
for advancing knowledge of biomedical
sources or for helping clinicians in
their daily care of patients I'm then
gonna be spending quite some time on
talking with you through some examples
of why computing language is difficult
and I'll give you some example both in
the general and in the house tomato and
then I'll move on to some approaches in
house natural language processing
there's been kind of a shift in
computing approaches and so it's
interesting to kind of even a review of
those and conclude with the current
developments in both domains in Eric NLP
and House NLP research so let me just
start by saying something that might be
obvious to you by now as human beings
which is that language is per visit
right like us as women when we talk to
each other we use language in written
and and not meet in the forum and the
big revolution for us in the computing
world is that there's more and more of
such instances of region text available
to us and so this is an example of a
identified clinical note and the things
to notice here which we are going to
become a theme or is that it's it's
English you know but it's it's not your
typical English right so like there's a
lot of abbreviations like HPI which
means history of present illness and so
if I meet if I were to read this first
sentence I would say a 77 year old male
with history of hypertension
ordinary artery disease status post
coronary artery bypass graft 1988
meaning that happened in 1988 and so
there you can already kind of think
about the challenges that we have here
right that we are trying to maybe
understand or extract some information
from this type of text and we have to
somehow be able to encode or to reason
about the fact that this node is that a
male patient of that particular age at
the time the note was written and some
procedures were given to the patient
like the cabbage and we actually even
have timing for these procedures but
there are also information about
medications symptoms disorders etc etc
another really important source of free
text for people who do NLP is the
literature as a scientific literature
and here you know there may be the
language is more it's more structured
but it's still very specific genre of
text right and there is there are
something that we can leverage we know
that scientific articles have some
structure to them there are backgrounds
methods results programs etc but they
also have you know slightly complex
sentences from a syntactic standpoint
and so if we want to be able to
understand what type of information is
being conveyed in these articles and do
so at scale across many articles then we
need to be able to probably be able to
parse these sentences accurately house
news are becoming an important source of
knowledge and trends in in-house and
other other domains as well I'm sure you
know outside of house there's all this
interesting new things happening with
fake news for example so how do we
detect that Samsung is a fake news how
do we detect that vitamin b12 is indeed
correlated with higher cancer risk it's
you could think of the house news
as a way to to disseminate the
information that's from the science but
with a very biased lands and
interestingly from an HMMP standpoint
with a yet a different style of language
and finally another type of text that is
of interest to natural language
processing people is all the information
that patients and house consumers are
exchanging on the social web so this is
an example from a breast cancer publicly
available breast cancer community and I
like this example because it kind of
described to us in a very clear fashion
whatever some of our issues are going to
be if we want to if we want to parse
this type of text and so this sounds
like a very exciting this is a thread
chain so Z is the first person writing
and she's very happy she said about
someone else that she's glad you found
Reggie but I hope you don't consume for
it the cuter one net or anything and it
sounds like it's not about cancer it
actually is about breast cancer but what
happens here is this common phenomenon
in online communities where the
community is coming up with their own
aggregations and nearly their own
register of language and so in fact
Reggie is regression of tumor and any D
or Ned is no evidence of disease and so
this is referring to the fact that
someone has my question of her tumor and
everyone is very happy there's a lot of
positive sentiment which can be easily
identified automatically but we also
would love to be able to automatically
identify that this person were talking
about had a regression in her tumor so
what are some of the applications that
have been heavily using NLP one that is
a a classic application and in a very
robust one by now and still at the same
time for interesting reason is becoming
yet again a newbie
question is automated coding clinical
notes so the task here is I have a
clinical notes typically a discharge
summary and I have on the other hand I
have a very large taxonomy of diagnosis
codes or icd-9 codes and I would like to
be able to automatically say what are
the must say eight or ten or fifteen
likely codes that can help me build for
a visit or that can help me we present
what this note is about so from a
computing standpoint the difficulty here
is twofold
right there's on one hand we have free
text and second difficulty is that it's
not a simple text categorization task
because it's a multi-label
classification but the universe of
labels is really really white so icd-9
codes there's about 15,000 of them and
I'm sure you guys know we've we've
actually in the United States now have
moved to icd-10 coding where now we're
talking about 65,000 plus codes so again
from a computing standpoint how do we
train other reasons to recognize what
are the most likely codes is an
interesting question in a very classical
question of NLP where NLP has been used
again in the clinical world is the one
of cohort detection and I know you have
had a lecture on information retrieval
so I'm not going to go too much into it
but it's an important one I by the way I
gave example of articles that I think
represent very well what what the NLP
challenges are and what the tasks or
methods are and so that you're welcome
to go and look at them but they're just
simple examples there's actually quite a
lot of research on those each of those
areas and so here again the the the
interesting fact is that if we want to
select a cohort to say from the
electronic health record so if we want
to identify in the electronic health
record who are the patients who have a
particular disease in this example we're
talking about
for all arterial disease then we know we
could use some of the meta data that's
available to us but we also would
probably want to use or leverage the
clinical notes and as a matter of fact
it turns out that when it comes to
identifying cohorts the NLP is often
quite critical to identifying the right
population clinical decision support is
a traditional example of clinical
informatics where again NLP would be
useful the idea here is to leverage the
information from clinical notes within
the logic of clinical decisions so if we
want to have an alert that looks at
potentially dangerous drug drug
interactions at the time of prescription
in the electronic health record or if we
want to make sure that we're not
prescribing the drug when a patient has
a specific allergy
this type of clinical decision support
system will go and look at the
structured information or the meta data
available in the electronic health
record but again there is no guarantee
that there's some information that all
the information about the patient is
included in the structured product of
the EHR and in fact very often old
allergies or or old you know things kind
of fall through the cracks and are
documented in the notes but not in the
structural part and so NLP here again is
extremely helpful another type of
application is one of data exploration
and this comes from the fact that
there's so much text available to
clinicians to health practitioners to
researchers that we need to help and
support them in just making sense of all
the data that's available so this is an
example of a patient record record
summarization system that we have at
Columbia University and is actually
deployed and used by physicians and the
idea here is that we're taking all of
the notes longitudinally from we have
about 20 plus years
worth of data for each of our patient
and we can through natural language
processing identify what are the primary
problems for that patient and on top of
it have a visualization an interactive
visualization that allows the clinicians
and and EHR workers to explore and go
through the timeline of a patient this
is another example of how the dykes NLP
can be used for data exploration this
isn't a slightly different genre of text
we're looking at purchasing spectrum
disorder communities so these are
equations sorry parents of children
typically with who are on the ASD
spectrum and the question again is
there's a lot of discussions how do I
make sense of all of these discussions
why would I want to do this maybe I'm a
public health practitioner and I want to
look into you know house communication
issues or maybe I want to learn about
how parents are viewing certain
treatments or what easy awareness about
particular disorders or symptoms for
patients and so here what we've done is
we've we've created a a set of named
entity recognition system that can
identify turns and posts and so on the
top right here is an example of a
snippet from a post and we then did so
for all the posts in the community and
built again a visualization to help with
exploration on top that kind of builds a
network of significantly occurring
charge pairs of terms and so in this
case we are in again an autism community
and so swimming is a very specific to
the language and the register and the
domain of autism but it's interesting to
see in which context basically that type
of term is being is being talked about
this is another example of data
exploration from text that has been
extremely successful in many different
many different areas actually and this
is one of topic modeling and so this is
taken from a paper that looked at all of
the publication's from science journal
and is trying to make sense in a very
unsupervised fashion about all the
different topics or themes that can that
have been talked about in in the science
journal over 100 100 plus years so what
is a challenge here the challenge is
that we do not know in advance we're not
we're completely unsupervised right we
do not know in advance we're not making
any hypotheses about what type of things
are being discussed in these articles
and we want a method that can allow us
to identify what are the primary themes
and moreover in the case of qualitative
models like in this example we want to
know how these seems related to each
other and so we can build this type
again a visualization that tells us that
you know RNA DNA and that type of
cluster of words here correspond to a
significant topic or cluster and more
other it is quite relevant related to me
it occurs or it correlates often with a
topic about sequencing and janna
sequencing and another one about
proteins for example so the value here
is that when you have a very very large
corpus given to you for example all of
the you know the all of the articles
published in a journal and you're trying
to extract to understand what order is a
primary topics discussed in that journal
like in this example or if you have a
patient cohort with lots of electronic
health record notes available to them or
if you have access to a normal Mouse
community for example prior to just
detecting particularly phenomenon maybe
want to just go and explore and
understand what is being talked about
and so a lot of NLP methods rely on this
type of topic modeling for data
exploration so another thing that you
can do with this type of topic modeling
is you can then look at how they change
through time so again this is from the
silence journal article where we have
you can look at these are examples of
two different topics and you can look at
through time from the earliest years of
publication of the science draw in 1818
up to 2000 what for example dimension of
the the term oxygen and what was
basically the interest maybe of oxygen
about the journal so keep in mind we're
not extracting information here we're
just identifying kind of salient terms
that are representative of the corpus
here and again it's not you know it's
not it should not be interpreted as a
literal representation of the corpus but
rather as a tool for data exploration
and a more and more prevalent type of
application has to come with
surveillance from publicly available
data set so this is a very active field
of research I'm I'm putting here just
two examples of papers but there are
many many more where we're looking at
the authors are looking at public social
media sources so things like Twitter or
Yelp and trying to identify very
specific occurrences of a condition in
this case the authors and the Department
of Health in the work ways are
interested in identifying who has had
foodborne illness after eating in a
restaurant so that they can go and maybe
look at you know go and investigate
what's going on with that restaurant so
what are the challenges again here from
from an NLP standpoint well on the top
left you see a yelp review and we want
to be able to knowing that we're looking
at foodborne illness we want to be able
to go and extract
that someone was sick but not only just
generally see that sick from eating and
that not only that the symptoms of
foodborne illness kind of happened after
enough time that it would kind of you
know support the idea that foodborne
illness came from that restaurant and so
it's a it's a complex information
extraction task there's a bit of
reasoning involved in here
another challenge is that it's you know
especially if we're talking about
Twitter not all of the information is
going to be nicely contained into a
single text and there is going to be
maybe conversations and all sorts of
like interesting linguistic phenomena
such as conferences that are going to be
needed to be taken care of to identify
for example like in this example on the
bottom right here that this person
indeed got sick and that that was a
particular location where the restaurant
was the potential culprit for the
foodborne illness researchers have been
thinking about this idea of info
surveillance quite a lot this is house
map which I encourage you to go and
visit this is work from Harvard and John
Bernstein and if you google house map
you'll find it right away and it's a
very nice interactive visualization of
all the potential diseases that are
being talked about on typically on the
on the news but they're incorporating
other data sources as well in here and
so again the same the same challenges
come again right how do we identify that
a particular disease is being talked
about and moreover in this case what is
the location of where the patients are
being notified about so let me switch
there and continue with my with my a
summary of applications this is going
back to the clinical domain we're
interested in high school food
phenotyping why do we want to do high
switch phenotyping we want to maybe be
able to identify our conditions that are
we talked about across a large horde of
patient or maybe we want to do that
centers escort identification but
instead of finding methods to do so very
well for one disease at a time maybe we
wanted to wait for all diseases at once
and the reason I'm bringing up this
example is mostly because the methods
are very similar to the one of topic
modeling and they're interesting because
they're checking into account not only
the the text but also the other data
structure information that we have in
the electronic health record such as
laboratory tests medications and
diagnosis codes and so we can build NLP
based methods that kind of incorporate
this additional information and bring
better here's basically to identify what
are the the observations that enable us
to decide that there is probably
diabetes mellitus type 2 for a
particular patient for example and so in
this case it's very much like topic
modeling it is in unsupervised method
and we can more other kind of have a
description of those typical conditions
or phenotypes we're looking for so for
example here we have lupus and we're
finding kind of again very unsupervised
fashion that anti-malarial are a
medication class that actually makes
sense for lupus and for the non
clinicians out there actually that's
correct
anti-material are a way of treating
lupus another type of application which
is really really big in healthcare but
is becoming really big also on our
social media type of situations is
predictive analytics so the question
here is you know can we use text either
in text which invalid patient or in this
case in this example that I'm giving
text about that are written by
individuals on reddit and can I predict
whether they are likely something is
likely to happen or there's likely to be
in a certain fashion so this example we
are interested in mental health and
there the author's are looking at
subreddits that have people talking
about their depression and then they're
looking there they want to know well
within within six months are they
actually now moving on to another type
of subreddit which is more about suicide
watch and so the question here is can I
predict that someone is gonna start I da
ting about suicide and it turns out that
there are very specific linguistic
indicators that can help us predict who
is going to be likely to move on from
the mental health type of subreddits to
the suicide watch type of subreddits you
can imagine there's a lot of interesting
applications that can come out of this
work but what's nice is that they
there's there is cues that come from the
syntax or from the type of words that
are being used by people where we can
actually predict what's gonna happen in
their behavior among online community
similarly in the clinical world we can
again try to predict adversity come so
here this is an example of a predictive
model that looks at progression of
chronic kidney disease and what's
interesting here is that because we're
in the clinical world we want to be able
to predict but we also want to be able
to interpret some of our learned rules
and so the type of methods that are used
here are again unsupervised and are are
basically learning topics together with
a kind of a temporal model which is a
Kalman filter in this case but primarily
for NLP purposes the point is that we
can learn topics of words that occur in
clinical notes that are going to be more
or less predictive predictive or
increasing risks for progression though
there is in orange / red topics in here
and the one that are going to be that
can have a protective effect
on patience and so that's again useful
because we can go further generate
hypotheses and work for service
clinicians on these questions okay so I
spent a lot of time on those
applications but I think it's it's
useful and again there's many many
others it's just useful hopefully for
you and it's definitely helpful for me
in my research to think very widely
about all the different type of texts as
data sources and knowledge sources for
various types of tasks we want to do but
I want to know focus on well okay so we
know that there are lots of applications
to to natural language processing but is
it you know why is it so hard and and
more like more specifically why can't I
just use regular expressions right like
so regular expression are just like
models of what I expect a set of string
or characters is going to look like and
it's going to help me search for a
particular type of information on the
large collection of text for example why
do I need more complex models of
language well the first question is the
first problem is that language is
ambiguous and it's ambiguous at all
linguistic levels and Frizzles
interested in what I mean by linguistic
levels morphology lexical level syntax
discourse and pragmatics are all are all
interesting levels to think about and
here are some of the example that are
the classic examples and so these
examples are they can actually taken
from the excellent excellent course I'm
Chris Manning at Stanford or natural
language processing and so here's one
where there's definitely some syntactic
ambiguity but paralyzed after two more
fights back to game black belt sign for
is this other headline in the new San
Jose cops kill man with wife will sorry
kill man with knife so where is the
ambiguity here well are we saying that
who had the knife basically everything
that the cops had knife and that's how
they killed man
are we saying that the cops killed a man
who had a knife and so that type of
annuity is called a PP attachment and
dignity we don't know if we were to
build a syntactic purse for that
sentence we don't know where we should
attach that phrase this knife should be
attached to the head to the noun phrase
man or should we attach it to the noun
phrase San Jose cops
it's actually ambiguous we do not know
we do know maybe as humans when we read
it because maybe there's you know
there's there's some more likely
scenario but it's still ambiguous there
could be of a scenario where the cops
are killing the man whose life sorry
that wasn't me - yes - are you killing a
man and they're using the knife to kill
him
some of our more clinical examples where
ambiguity we've seen are very lexical
for us in clinical texts this is an
actual example from a social history of
a patient and says patient sister in see
a mother breast CA and so we have here a
term a term which is as here which
happens to be in abbreviation and those
type of aggravation are usually fairly
ambiguous in the first occurrence of CA
women in California in the second one we
mean cancer and in particular breast
cancer so how do we how do we build a
language of more a language model that
can help us disambiguate between these
these cases moreover there's other since
science census - this type of text -
type of terms for example CA also means
calcium so this lexical ambiguity it's
quite difficult
the other challenge with language is one
of variability and again it happens at
own linguistic levels another way to
think of it is that there's a high
paraphrasing power in language and it's
a good thing actually because we're not
you know as humans we want to have
ability to create and new ways of saying
new
things but also all things there usually
are some reasons to why you would say
when one a sentence one way or another
but for the sake of computing we want to
be able to identify that maybe different
forms of a term actually refer to the
same the same concepts like on the
example on the Left diabetes mellitus 2
diabetes t2 TM all of these three and
many others how can I build a model that
recognizes that these guys are all
talking about type 2 diabetes and note
that I put diabetes here as an example
and that's actually ambiguous are we
talking about type 1 or type 2 diabetes
and so maybe there's some some
additional reasoning that would tell me
that in my corpus really when I say
diabetes I'm in type 2 diabetes and I'm
able to map all of or normalize all of
these forms to a single concept and so
that's an example of variability I'm a
lexical standpoint but there's obviously
a lot of variability in syntactically
john loves Mary Mary is loved by John
the man who is named john loves Mary all
of these things meet the sensing your
paraphrases of each other and are
nevertheless conveyed with different
syntactic structures it's interesting to
think further about the lexical
ambiguity and and really go back to that
question about diabetes is that you know
it is to remain diabetes type 2 in
general so the context is really helpful
in these things and and as a matter of
fact a lot of the computational methods
are incorporating context to to
determine this type of language models
and so I thought I would show you a very
simple visualization of what we mean by
context so here we have two online
health communities one is the same
autism spectrum disorder discussion firm
that I mentioned earlier and the other
one is a general parenting discussion
forum and we again we built a
a representation of all the terms that
are being mentioned in those forums and
we do some normalization as much as we
can but we also then try to look for
co-occurrences patterns okay and so two
terms are gonna have in this network and
edge between them if they cooker
together or more often than they do not
and so why am I putting these two
networks here those are networks
centered actually on a single node on
the node drug here and the similarly
here on the ASD on your left about the
node drug but as it is mentioned in the
ast in deities and communities and so
when do we see well it's two different
very very different networks right and
clearly you can say a lot about even
though they are exactly the same terms
they mean completely different things in
different context right and so in the
general branching forum drug is
typically meant as in illicit or illegal
drug or a problematic drug like alcohol
marijuana substance abuse pharmaceutical
company is more about the format type of
drug and illicit those are the terms
that are found as being statistically
important related to drug in the autism
world they mean clearly they mean
different types of drugs and moreover
all of these drugs are very
representative of the type of treatment
that children on the spectrum are using
so again from an NLP standpoint the
interest here is that even though there
are terms that have exactly the same
lexical information they actually mean
different things in different complexed
and so a lot of the methods that are
being developed nowadays have to do with
language modeling which is trying to
represent or encode what is the meaning
of the set of a particular word through
what type of words they occur Okakura is
this is a similar example again language
to same word on both sides means very
very different things in two types of
context in general parenting when people
took parents talk about language they
mean the foreign language or maybe
bilingual language whereas in autism
community language is all about all of
the potential symptoms related to autism
as well as potential therapies that have
to do with with helping with an image
difficulties okay so the the last one
the last challenge that I would focus on
through very simple examples is the fact
that language is vague and another way
to think about it is that maybe we need
to reason about language and and like
for the ambiguity and the variability
challenges its present at all lexical
levels so there are three types of
example that I want to focus on first
one is one that we see quite a lot in
the clinical world this is two sentences
am i three weeks ago and my three days
ago so what's the question here we first
of all we need to recognize that mi
means myocardial infarct in this case
that's right that's a lexical ambiguity
or freezing power question but here I
want to focus on that temporal
expression here which days three weeks
ago and here it says three days ago if
we want to actually reason over those
information and if we want to understand
or represent the meaning of those
occurrences we need to understand that
first of all this is a temporal
representation a temporal expression and
moreover it is about that clinical event
which was a micro do in fact the last
thing you'd want to do then is to say
well okay so if we were to establish a
timeline of events of the patient then I
would I would use a time at which the
note was written and I would go three
weeks in the past and and put the
myocardial infarct
at that time right that would be the
sensible thing to do automatically turns
out that in the clinical world that's
not always correct that's not always the
right thing to do
I mean it's it is the right thing to do
but it's it's more complex than that and
so what's going on well we can actually
find that when someone says am i three
days ago in fact the person said three
days ago they really meant that it it
happened three days ago but when someone
says a clinician says three weeks ago
well it could be three weeks ago
twenty-one days ago that it could be
twenty days ago or 19 days ago or
something like that and it sounds like
it's not an important problem it
actually is quite an important problem
for two reasons one is that it's not
always the case that this type of
temporal information is available in the
structured part of the electronic health
record we really want to rely on the
notes because the notes are often
talking about events that did not happen
in a current institution or you know
Paris for various reasons the second one
is if we want to study temporal or
time-related phenomena like adverse drug
reactions or prediction of particular
events we really want to have the
timeline down correctly and so how do we
you know how do we know that when
someone says three weeks ago that really
meant you know 21 days plus or minus
four days whereas when someone says
three days ago that really means three
days ago that's we need some reasoning
here or at least we need a way to encode
this type of uncertainty about the
language speaking of uncertainty the
next example is interesting as well and
that's that's something that happens
actually very often in the clinical and
in the house domain so when I say Paul
thinks that john loves Mary there are a
few things that are happening right from
a linguistic standpoint first is that
there's a fact that says that John was
Mary and I know we you know what can we
say about that fact is it is it true
I'm true what is you know when do we
know exactly we actually do not know
whether that fact is true but we know
that a third person thinks that that
fact is true
similarly this type of like pragmatic
things creep up even in clinical energy
when someone says you know patient
denies smoking we're not say you know
that's typically you found that as like
vision does not smoke but really when we
think about it it really means I do not
know whether the patient smokes or not
but I'm gonna encode it and I'm gonna
represent it by saying the patient
denies it it's it's something to think
about when we do this type of
information extraction and and
unreasoning in the health domain that
comes quite often you can imagine if a
patient says you know write a question
on mine on searches for some symptoms
somewhere or rights to their peers and
they often would say you know I think
this is happening and there's a lot of
uncertainty about all of this phenomenon
that they're discussing and so the least
the last thing we would want to do as
NLP practitioners would be to extract
this information and just say oh look it
says john loves Mary I'm gonna just
extract that fact as being true and
ignores its other part of the sentence
so taking into account this uncertainty
of languages is very interesting the
final type of reasoning that's needed is
coming I think is it was treated well by
that tweet example where this person
says that they just ate a bowl of xanax
for breakfast it's true it's a
well-formed sentence which basically
does not happen often on Twitter so
that's good there's you know even the
medication is well written in here so
there's no problem of like identifying
that then X min xanax the question is
did this patient actually get this
person actually eat a bowl of xanax for
breakfast probably not right and so is
it sarcasm is it humor or did this
person actually mean that they didn't
eat a whole bowl of it but maybe they
ate a lot of xanax and maybe that want
to be you know we
want to pay attention to that type of
signal when doing money trigger of
Twitter we want to be able to build
models that can recognize that there's
something uncertain about this
information
okay so approaches to health NLP I don't
actually many many different approaches
out there and I made kind of like an
editorial choice you know focusing on
two types of methods and I'll talk about
a third one in the current developments
but keep in mind again I'm just giving
you an overview and I definitely suggest
that you if you're interested in the
field of natural language processing in
the health domain they're wonderful
classes online and tutorials and I'm
happy to if you want to get in touch
with me to point you to some of them so
something that a task for which a lot of
methods have been designed over time in
clinical texts and clinical NLP is one
of information extraction so the task is
if I have a sentence like this one
patient should come back if severe
facial rash occurs I want to be able to
do some what's called named entity
recognition meaning that I recognize
that facial rash is a disorder is a type
of problem that can happen to a patient
not only that it's a particular concept
in a terminology in this case I'm
showing will concept in the UN is the
unified medical language system which is
a really large terminology and and maybe
I'd like to extract other modifiers
about these particular disorders so in
this case maybe I would want to identify
that severe is an important modifier
here and the if here is also as you can
imagine quite important and is
indicating that this is a conditional
type of disorder in other words the
patient actually does not have a facial
rash but but the facial rash is
discussed nevertheless in
the context of this particular patient
so what other type of modifiers have
been thought about many many different
ones this is an example of set of
modifiers for disorders we would want to
normalize to a terminology we would want
to be able to identify negation who is a
subject of that disorder is who is the
disorder attributed to another way to
think about it
is there a uncertainty is there some
sort of like progression or course
mentioned about that disorder what is
the severity of the disorder is it
conditional like in the example earlier
or is it is it actually not a disorder
like in this example when we say the
patient goes to the HIV clinic really it
says HIV and HIV is a disorder but HIV
clinic his religion and entity
recognition with one of the attention to
and if there is a particular body
location that's affected by the disorder
like facial rash facial is actually part
of the important body location we would
want to extract here so there's been a
lot of work in natural language
processing to kind of define this type
of schemas to figure out what it is that
we want to extract in clinical texts
like this one that's one type of work
and typically this is done through lots
of annotations of text and there's a
whole field of research about how to do
these annotations in a way that is
correct in a way that we can trust the
type of annotation that we found that
the schemas are a generic enough and can
be applied to many different type of
information extraction systems and then
of course we want to be able to build
methods that are going to actually use
the schema and then go on new type of
text and identify those named entity
being mentioned along with all of these
modifiers this is a really really large
field of research in clinical NLP and so
I just I am giving here like literally
three examples of like famous papers
here on this domain but there are many
many more the example I'm giving
here is from the CTX from the CTX system
which is actually open source and you
can try if you have any clinical text
and the reason I like it is it kind of
shows you all of the different setup
part of the pipeline that the system
goes through in order to do these named
entity recognition so there's a fact
there is a sentence here that says
family of obesity family history FX is a
is a an abbreviation for family history
of obesity but no family history of
coronary artery disease the first
question is how do we tokenize and this
I believe in the text wrangling lecture
you guys had some discussion of that we
wanna then identify the part of speech
of all of those different sentences the
different words in the sentences and
maybe just what's called a shallow
parsing meaning we would identify not
the whole syntactic structure of the
sentence but rather what are the primary
noun phrases so a noun phrase would be a
term a set of words that together refer
to unknown ahead none and from there we
would then go and look for particular
noun phrases that can be matched to a
terminology like here so obesity is
found and coronary artery disease is
found but also coronary artery and
artery and diseases and all of those are
potential named entities we would want
to identify furthermore as a status for
a family history sorry for obesity is
that it's a family history as opposed to
the patient has obesity and the and it's
not negated so the nowadays I think that
the state of the art type of non
tentative information system are using
sequence labelers and again Center
heritage you kind of mentioned it and so
I I thought I would move on from them
but you can see what I mean here by
sequence level right like where I'm able
to go through each of these turns each
of these words
and I'm slowly building up these
particular term coronary artery disease
by saying that this is the beginning of
my entity and I'm gonna keep in my
sequence of turns until I I feel like it
doesn't belong to the to the named
entity anymore
I mean you've you've heard me refer to
terminology is quite a lot and this is
outside the scope of this of this
lecture but you you realize I hope that
we're relying heavily in this type of
clinical tasks on Mexicans or
terminologies or intelligence and one
huge challenge is how do we ensure that
the lexicon actually captures the
language of the corpus under study the
umls is very is very large but it's also
quite specific for example to clinical
and technical type of language and so
know when we are doing work in online
house communities or on Twitter we need
to figure out ways to either augment or
filter as you MLS and I know if you can
help for this as well another type of
approach that's been really helpful and
I've mentioned is one of Provost ectopic
model and I would like to be free resist
of all the work of David Bly and all of
the people who worked on this for the
past ten plus years but the idea here is
very different approach to clinical
intensity regulation and is looking at
inmates completely unsupervised and is
trying to find patterns of of of text
and in particular is trying to ID
identify cluster of words that tend to
cook her quite often with each other
such that the documents that they appear
on are considered to be a probabilistic
mixture of those of those clusters or
topics and so you can add the output of
your topic modeling board in this case
latent dirichlet allocation you can
identify that all these different words
together are very likely to be part of
that topic and moreover we could think
of that topic as humans as being about
genetics for evolution which is
particularly for that example I have not
talked at all about evaluation but this
is something that people think a lot
about in-house natural language
processing there's a lot of tasks evade
evaluation so when you do progression
progression of disease we think of a
test based evaluation as did I predict
who is going to progress accurately and
that's fine
but when you think about the core and RP
methods we do usually need gold standard
annotations to do some sort of
validation or internal validation or
intrinsic evaluation of the core inaptly
methods and again it's a whole topic so
I'm not touching on it but I'm
mentioning it here okay so I want to
finish with the current developments in
house NLP and nmp research and this is a
very exciting type of research that is
happening for the past five less than
five years actually and which is the
event of deep neural nets in the world
of linguistics and so I am NOT I I felt
like I couldn't really point to you to
very specific papers but if you are
interested in the context of deep
learning and natural language processing
with Richard Sutter at Stanford has an
excellent class and all the material is
given online and so I suggest that you
go and either read or even try to do the
homework but I thought basically there's
like four areas that are very
interesting I think from the NLP
standpoint as far as like new areas of
work what is a better or improved
language models we know already that we
need a clue Tekonsha contextual
representation of what words are and
knows who neural nets we have better
contextual representations not only of
the words but what the sequence of the
words or even sequence of characters
represent and that has been shown to be
extremely powerful we have better
sequence models and so remember that
named entity recognition tasks where
we're looking for
of words that together define a medical
charm for instance record neural nets
either on words or on characters are
very exciting because it can capture
which long distance dependencies in text
which was not possible with more
different models like CRF for example
finally there is really interesting work
in models learning models for mixed
modalities so what I mean by mix
modalities things like text plus images
text plus laboratory tests etc and and
so you know we've had some example in
the applications where we know that by
incorporating all of this metadata if
you want about a patient or about a
individual and a online we can we can
actually predict better or understand
better what this person is talking about
or what a doctor is talking about with
respect to a patient and finally there's
interesting new type of machine learning
I'm thinking about adversarial neural
nets and reinforcement learning in
particular where that are trying to
starting to show some very useful
progress in an appeal so again I'm not
pointing you to any specific papers but
if you're interested there's there are
some classes online for you to look at
ok so I want to focus conclude by
telling you that language is pervasive
it's hard to process automatically and
sometimes it's also hard for humans but
that's because there is ambiguity there
is variability and vagueness but there's
much progress that has been done and I
have finished by saying that this is an
active field of research both in terms
of the core NLP methods that are being
developed but also in ways of thinking
of how to leverage text in general for
biomedical knowledge discovery
characterizing diseases and behavior
improving care etc so with that I'll
stop and hopefully there's enough time
for questions
thank you dr. Ella dot for her great
talking over Theo Anna and I'll p.m.
sort of the medical and health too
so we have one question for you from the
audience the first this first question
is regarding privacy issues and so
you've been a lot of the examples that
you gave are from from social media like
Reddit and other areas forums and such
could you address how issues related to
privacy and potentially
de-identification are addressed in this
type of work obviously that house
applications also more specifically when
your mind in clinical records but if you
could touch broadly upon that that would
be appreciated great yes that's a great
question and and you're right I didn't
talk about this um so so typically you
know and I give you an overview of like
different papers out there and everyone
has a you know everyone has their own
idea of their own institution that
usually makes sure that the methods are
being you know respectful of the
participants in this case the people who
write those texts or the people about
which these texts are written so when it
comes to online house communities and
social media you know most of the papers
I've seen till is publicly available you
know data sets and and text corpora so
for example this breast cancer data set
that I mentioned very early on is is
completely available online Twitter is
available if you don't pay attention to
private messages etc there are eight
some there are some questions about how
would you say you will and crawl in the
entirety of an online house community
how do you go about distributing these
data as researchers we do not have the
right to distribute it we need to have
you know somehow the agreement of the
people who created and our monitoring
this this data and so people have been
looking a lot into how to de-identify
text there are some both commercial and
research the identifiers out there and
it turns out it's a very institution
specific type of thing where some
institutions are okay with letting you
distribute your data if you if
gentrified it and others are not there
already identified clinical corpora out
there mimic is one of them
and there are there are publicly
available you know online house
community out there great so our second
question is actually a valuation what is
the typical error rate in interpreting
these texts as the applied natural
language processing techniques obviously
it's not necessarily perfect and as you
pointed out there's a lot of inherent
vagueness to the text even humans are
not necessarily perfect but could you
discuss what the typical error rate
might be and are there any examples
where any misinterpretations have
actually led to bad decisions hmm okay
so so I feel like this is like kind of
like two questions like unintended
consequences of recognition of something
and what is a typical error rate it's
hard it's hard to say what typical is
you know if you think of a named entity
recognition system it's typically built
with a terminology in mind for a
particular type of text and so if I take
you MLS and seat X and apply it to or
meta map or medley and applied to an
autism community I might find that I
have an error rate of say you know forty
percent in F measure but if I were to do
exactly the same and apply it to
clinical notes I would have an error
rate of like 85 F measure so it's it's
difficult to say you know it's difficult
to to say out of the you know without
without thinking of the task the the
corpus and the terminologies for example
how accurate typically an entity
recognition system is and what this is
pointing at is that there's there is not
a whole lot of benchmarking in-house NLP
but that's something that the community
is working on heavily so there have been
for the past few years datasets that
have been you know j identified in the
case of clinical text where gold
standard annotations are provided
for people to share and they and we
there are challenges that you know let's
many different research groups try
different methods but everyone agrees to
use the same evaluation metrics
understand understand benchmark
annotations and text and we can then
compare you know and understand which
methods work better than another I would
say though that we're not we're probably
not as far ahead as we could be compared
to other domains of NLP and other areas
of machine learning in part because of
those privacy issues for sure great so
we're actually at 10 o'clock now so
being mindful at the time thank you
again so much for for giving this talk
and look we'll close it here happy
holidays everyone we will we'll be back
in January 2017 with the next set of
talks thank you very much